there's this story of a brooding
self-serious young actor a young hot
thing
making waves in hollywood and he's he's
burdened with the desire to
to really be an artist right to to
pierce the veil to show someone
something
to show others something they've never
seen before i mean he really
he he sees himself as a serious actor he
wants to become a mythic figure he wants
to make
art that lasts and he's brooding with
with with this um this this
this desire for perfection and for
transcendence and
and one day he sits down with a veteran
actor
you know a legendary mythic veteran
and he and he broods to him he says i
just i want to be great i want to be
great like you were great i want to be
great
like the greats that we that we talk
about you know
i want to matter i want to i want to be
significant i want my art
to reach people to touch people
otherwise i'll be a
personal failure otherwise i won't
matter nothing that i do will matter and
i want to make
art that matters right and then the the
veteran actor looks at him
and says you know what the [ __ ]
problem with you young bucks is
i'll say i'll sum it up for you in one
sentence
i'll sum it up for you stop trying to
make art
stop trying to make art and just become
art stop trying to make art stop with
the brooding self-obsession start with
the narcissism start
stop with the sociopathy you know stop
with
with all of this gnarly self obsession
like eating you up from inside like stop
trying to make
art you must become art and what does
that mean
well it means you have to die
a little you have to die to who you were
you have to die to your expectations you
have to die somewhat to your plans
you have to die to being able to predict
what's going to happen you have to
surrender you have to let go you have to
get
out of your own way you must experience
a form of unselfing you must be cracked
open
you must be [ __ ]
broken apart and only when you're on the
other side of this resignation only once
you've been cracked open only
after you've died can you hope to meet
the world not as a person but as a myth
as as as as
as as a as an
echo or or a reflection of an experience
that was larger than you were
you know does that make sense the
greatest actors they transcend
themselves we're not we're not looking
at that person
anymore we're looking at a living myth
we're looking at somebody who has slayed
themselves and put themselves
aside you know the mythic figures they
tell us the cave you fear holds the
treasure you seek these people
went there the true artists went there
they they took a gamble man like jordan
peterson says they
they contended with the unknown you know
like they [ __ ] slayed the dragon
their solar plexus was vibrating at 500
rpms per second they died
they died and only then they achieved
transcendence and then
it's whatever they're able to to bring
back from that experience somatically in
their body if even a glimpse
some intimation of that lightning was
captured in a bottle then my friends
you've got transcendent art
then you've got the ark of the covenant
and us mere viewers you know
mere audience goers you know we can look
inside the ark of the covenant and god
is in there but if you look at it you
die
in other words to experience great art
also is to slay yourself even the
watcher even the viewer
even the audience has to die right stop
trying to make art stop trying to watch
art just
become art just become art
[Music]